oh hey fella pick your poison whiskey
whiskey hey want a chaser for that
maybe coke whiskey coke back coke back
Mountain those men loved each other
Anna don't ya maybe you want an antidote
chaser
they're the poison you just drank that
was poison poison yeah that's poison
deadly poison I didn't ask for poison
yes you did it's a contract between
customer and bartender if I say pick a
poison and you say something I have to
give you poison
it's the Hippocratic oath that's doctors
sounds like that poisons already eaten
at your brain that's what it does I
don't want to make a choice on that
antidote clock's ticking
I'm worried safer arm brunt ball I'm the
woman all this and Andy Rooney who's
dead on 60 minutes yeah yeah I want the
antidote
you sure what does the antidote it's
mostly Clamato juice just forget it
you know I get that a lot who invented
that aboard sailor with shellfish in the
tomato let's sell this where everywhere
but america tastes like you blew a
hangover
I'm just saying me I'd rather watch the
world burn than drink an ounce of
Clamato juice where's that tub the Pete
Holmes show premieres October 28th after
Conan only on TBS meet Pete at Pete
Holmes calm